should we he might be in contention for
MVP this is really the first we've seen
LeBron all weekend he had a lot of
commitments back home watching Brawny
and Sierra Canyon play and Giannis is
out here with that wrist injury
everything is going to be with the left
hand it looks like John golpo Mark
Lindsey Michael Smith our three
officials and Giannis will dunk it down
and that's how the 72nd NBA All-Star
Game begins
is going to take the foul all right so
maybe a little Chris Paul situation from
last year Giannis
appreciate all the effort yeah you got
to love him he's going to give
everything he has every single night and
I'm sure Bucks fans and Bucks Personnel
namely head coach Mike bodenholzer glad
to see Jonas come immediately out of
this game
in the box score and uh